herzlich willkommen mitten in der natur
hier oben auf dem campus irchel der
universität zürich erforscht einer der
weltweit renommiertesten anthropologen
karin van schaik interesse ich jetzt
gleich im museum für anthropologie wo er
uns zu den anfängen der menschheit führt
k s an zeigt dass hier sind unsere
nächsten verwandten
wie kommt es eigentlich dass wir heute
in klimatisierten büros sitzen derweil
unsere verwandten immer noch im urwald
hocken
das ist genau die allerwichtigste frage
der evolutionäre anthropologie das ist
unsere aufgabe das zu lösen
denn es ist ja heutzutage unumstritten
dass die tiere sind
das ist kein problem mehr aber die
wenigsten leute wissen dass wir
afrikanischen menschenaffen sind also
wie diese menschen laufen habe ich noch
eine kleine überraschung für sie wenn
wir jetzt diese drei arten vergleichen
gorillas schimpansen menschen
welches paar ist jetzt am nächsten
verwandt naja wie sie denken gorillas
schimpansen aldi sehen sich so ähnlich
genau und man kann sogar zeigen dass
gorillas einfach schimpansen sind die
ein bisschen länger weiter gewachsen
sind
trotzdem legen wir da falsch denn sowohl
die molekularbiologie als auch bestimmte
anatomische merkmale zeigen dass die
nächsten verwandten also die an den
jüngsten gemeinsamen vorfahren haben
schimpansen und menschen sind mit ihnen
teilen die nahezu 99 prozent unseres
gehen gutes gehen diese tiere eigentlich
das ist auch so eine überraschung würde
ja denken ja die gehen alle gleich und
wir gehen anders deshalb sind wir ja
wirklich von denen getrennt hat man
jahrhunderte gedacht aber nein sie gehen
also auf diesen knöcheln
wir gehen aufrecht aber wie es jetzt
aussieht haben die das unabhängig
voneinander entwickelt und menschen
haben anders reagiert auf die
notwendigkeit um auf dem boden zu gehen
denn die vorfahren waren ja alle
hängende tiere die in den bäumen so
hangeln sie in den baumkronen gelebt
haben sind alle heruntergekommen
obwohl sich noch häufig in den bäumen in
den bäumen essen sowie unsere vorfahren
auch gemacht haben und wir sind dann
aufrecht gegangen
und die haben das anders gelöst
sie gehen auf den knöcheln gehen wir mal
da drüben da sind die orang utans das
sind ja offen die sie sehr lang
erforscht haben sie waren immer wieder
während vielen jahren auf borneo und
sumatra
was haben sie herausgefunden als sie
diese orang utans beobachtet haben
das erste was natürlich auffällt ist sie
sind ähnlich wie bei den schimpansen und
gorillas sind auch unglaublich schlau
und was wir herausgefunden haben ist wie
diese intelligenz entsteht das ist nicht
einfach man wird geboren man ist schlau
die kinder die sind wie unsere babys die
wissen eigentlich nichts die können
nichts die werden dass alle über viele
jahre hinaus lernen sie ihre fähigkeiten
und das wichtigste was wir gesehen haben
ist das alles lernen ist sozial
gesteuert also die die gehen nicht
einfach herum und versuchen sich sachen
zu lernen nein das wird alles wird von
der mutter abgeschaut und wenn dann zum
glück denn die sind noch einmal
einzelgängerisch auch nochmal anderen da
sind dann schauen sie auch von denen ab
und wir können sogar zeigen dass in wenn
eine population geselliger ist man bei
den orange ist das ja nicht so häufig
davon aber es gibt kooperationen sind
sehr gesellig
dann lernt man mehr fähigkeiten diese
populationen sind technologisch
avancierte haben einfach mehr gescheite
techniken usw populationen wo man nur
die mutter hat ein plädoyer für teamwork
sozusagen
heute forschen sie ja mit krallenaffen
was fasziniert sie denn an den kahlen
affen werden müssen wieder zurückkommen
auf die große frage wieso sind wir so
anders denn wir sind ja fast 99 prozent
mädchen verwandt aber keine würde sich
da wehren und sagen sie sind schimpanse
oder und so also das ist eindeutig
anders
und dann müssen wir wahrscheinlich etwas
suchen das nichts mit den heutigen
menschenaffen zu tun hat und deshalb
kamen wir auf die carina finden was
wissen wir von den heutigen menschen
heutige menschen die jäger sammler sind
was wir auf im fachbereich corporate
breeders nennen die ziehen ihre kinder
gemeinsam auf alle helfen mit
menschenaffen tun das nicht
kann man sagen die die mieter sind alle
alleinerzieher also die hier die müssen
ihre kinder selber aufziehen genau da
wird nicht geholfen von anderen bei uns
ist das grundsätzlich tv und jetzt
glauben wir dass das vielleicht der
auslöser war
wieso wir so schnell so anders geworden
sind dann müssen wir also etwas über
dieses kapitel breeding lernen das
können wir bei den primaten unsere
gruppe nur lernen bei den grafen das
sind die einzigen die das auch machen
wir schauen uns natürlich auch andere
seite und vögel an die das ausmachen
damit wir ein bild bekommen
was sind die konsequenzen von dieses von
ihrem corporate branding gemeinsame
jungen aufzucht gemeinsames aufziehen
der jungen macht offensichtlich schlau
teamwork macht schlafen
die waren jetzt bei unseren nächsten
verwandten den menschenaffen jetzt
kommen wir hier zu unseren vorfahren ein
modell eines homo erectus sie im
schaukasten an lebte dieser mensch
dieses gerät ist so ungefähr 1,6
millionen jahren auf die art ist
wahrscheinlich ein bisschen älter aber
das sind die ersten waren menschen die
wir ganz eindeutig zu unserer gattung
zuordnen können
das erstaunt mich jetzt weiß wo ungefähr
acht bis zehn millionen jahren haben wir
uns ja quasi weiterentwickelt und in
offenbach und jetzt hier zwei millionen
jahre was ist denn in dieser langen
spanne passiert das wissen wir nicht
genau aber die ersten skelette die ganz
eindeutig aufrecht gegangen sind kann
man anatomisch gut sein wenn man die
überreste hat die sind ungefähr vor
sechs millionen jahren entstanden also
die die arzt dass das aufrecht gehen ist
schon ziemlich alt
aber da ist wenn man die die die die
sachen anschauen
das wird immer besser belegt zb vor drei
millionen jahren gab es die
australopithecus afarensis lucy können
alle mit fußspuren usw
die waren aber eigentlich könnte man
sagen einfach aufrecht gehende
menschenaffen da war nicht so viel
spannendes los was wir nicht auch schon
bei den menschenaffen sehen also die
geschichte ist ein umso erstaunlicher
dass wollen wir sagen menschwerdung das
ist nicht seit der abtrennung von den
vorfahren menschen passen
die ganze mensch währung so sich
abgelaufen hat aber das eigentlich das
ganze erst vor 2 200 millionen jahren
abgespielt und der aufrechte gang war
offenbar nicht das ausschlagen die
kriterien mensch zu werden können wenn
wir diese menschen hier ansehen die
leben offenbar in der savanne erlegen
tiere was ist denn in dieser zeit
passiert die haben die menschen gelegt
der entscheidende schritt war dass wir
uns da eine völlig neue nische kreiert
haben nicht wir gingen auf die savanne
vorher waren wir immer in der nähe von
bäumen denn immer hat man auch auf die
bäume geklettert dort geschlafen nester
gebaut und so weiter
und das bedeutet dass hier etwas ganz
neues passiert ist und wie das das bild
auch zeigt das ganz neue hat sehr
wahrscheinlich damit zu tun dass wir
jäger geworden sind das könnte
anatomisch zeigen diese korrekt skelette
weil sie so vollständig war kann man
zeigen hat unglaublich viele anpassungen
daran dass wir jogging also dieses
dieses runden auf das verfahren strafen
leisten langstreckenläufer sogar
marathon artig wahrscheinlich auch die
schulter zeigt dass sie das erste mal
geworfen haben so nicht wie sowie die
schimpansen aber so wie menschen das
machen und das bedeutet dass da etwas
ganz neues entstanden ist
das sehen wir auch in der technologie
den relativ plötzlich kommen da
plötzlich diese steinwerkzeuge was sehen
wir dass diese steinwerkzeuge gemacht
haben
die haben die hat man verwendet zum teil
wahrscheinlich um die tiere zu töten
obwohl meistens die tiere von
erschöpfung selber sterben wenn sie so
lange wir haben zu viel hitze und die
sterbende aber zum teil auch kann man
zeigen dass die knochen von diesen
tieren zeigen die spuren auf von diesen
steinwerkzeuge dass man sie und
vielleicht hat und das bedeutet dass wir
eine total neue nische einen neuen
lebensstil erfunden haben wann haben wir
begonnen feuer zu machen das ist
natürlich archäologisch schwierig zu
zahlen zu unterscheiden von natürliche
feuer oder kleine feuerstellen wenn zum
beispiel ein baum abgebrannt ist oder so
was
aber gut belegt ist es für 11 millionen
jahren
es gibt also viele spekulationen die
zahlen ja es könnte auch viel früher
sein
das würde es das im rahmen von homo
erectus bringen dass diese ganze
revolution könnte man sagen die sind
total unfähige lebensweise die wir jetzt
haben und statt bananen sagen einmal
fressen wir jetzt fleisch mit diesen
steinwerkzeug technologien mit den
anderen technologie diese revolution vor
ungefähr zwei millionen jahren hat uns
zu menschen gemacht ein wichtiger
entwicklungsschritt in der menschwerdung
ist ja das selbstbewusstsein und ich
habe einen spiegel mitgebracht der fall
scheint wenn sie sich hier drin
betrachten dann können sie sich erkennen
können dass auch menschenaffen
ja und das ist sehr speziell denn auch
wenn man das nicht zu glauben möchte das
können nur die wenigsten tiere und dass
das ist eine erstaunliche erfindung dass
jemand mal gesehen hat tiere erkennen
sich nicht im spiegel und menschenaffen
tun das schon denn was braucht es dafür
was ist was ist notwendig um sich selber
zu erkennen
das ist dann muss man irgendwie ein
vergleich machen
man muss also eine erwartung haben wie
man aussieht und das muss man dann
abgleichen mit was man tatsächlich sieht
also das ist viel komplizierter hat man
so denken müsste und das hängt mit sehr
vielen anderen sachen zusammen man muss
aus irgendwie eine repräsentation haben
von etwas das nicht direkt durch die
sinnesorgane reinkommt ist auch etwas
was die kinder erst mit der zeit lernen
gesamt zwei jahren kann die sich im
spiegel erkennen welche tiere können
dass dennoch außer den menschenaffen
also alle menschen offen können es gibt
gute hinweise dass delphinus können es
gibt hinweise des elefanten es können
und es gibt vielleicht ein paar
vogelarten das ist ein bisschen alles
nächste sachen wissen umstritten aber
das sieht ziemlich gut aus so dass das
ist nicht etwas das nur einmal
entstanden ist das ist konvergenz schon
mehrfach entstanden
das hat mit großem hirn zu tun und wie
gesagt dieses repräsentieren von sachen
die man nicht direkt sehen kann und dass
man diese repräsentationen manipulieren
kann
und das erklärt unglaublich viel von was
wir bei den welchen außen sie nicht
manipulieren also sagen wir mal eine ein
kopfkino machen damit also zum beispiel
was bei uns unglaublich wichtig ist es
ist so genannte serie auf meint dass ich
irgendwie eine ahnung habe dass sie eine
andere person sind dass sie vielleicht
anders sehen als ich schaue in diese
richtung sich ein in diese richtung das
ist der erste schritt das können
schimpansen schon aber der zweite
schritt dass ich weiß zum beispiel ob
sie durst haben oder nicht und das
vielleicht ein bisschen wasser trinken
wollen und so weiter dass wir haben sie
ein siedlung das einfühlen auf der auf
der kognitiv anspruchsvollen ebene
das hat mit diesen manipulationen von
repräsentation und zu tun wenn ich mich
selber noch nicht mal erkennen kann ich
auch keinen anderen erkennen also und es
gibt eine ganze menge von sachen also
wir haben spiegel erkennen wir haben
tiere auf meint dass zeitreisen ist er
wirklich ein kopfkino sich vorstellen
was ich morgen mache oder was ich
gestern getan
das können menschenaffen ein bisschen
die menschen tun das den ganzen tag man
kann sogar zeigen dass dieses sogar das
sogenannte die forke dem hirn macht nur
das wenn wir an nichts denken tun wir
das also dass das hat alles damit zu tun
und spiegel erkennen wie einfach es auch
ist ist eigentlich der beweis dafür dass
es all diese fähigkeiten die die
gebündelten fähigkeiten gibt eine frage
die auch immer aufkommt ist ob tiere
eigentlich so was haben die an moral
empfinden die moralisch sein können
und da gibt es eine schöne
versuchsanordnung da wurden
kapuzineräffchen mit deiner aufgabe
betraut die einen haben als belohnung
eine gurke erhalten die anderen eine
taube und das ist ein experiment was die
uns jetzt gemeinsam anschauen wollen
das ist von der sarah braun und frans de
waal
carel van schaik etwas zeigen dieses
experiment also wir wissen dass tiere
freundschaftsbeziehungen pflegen
wo sie austauschen ich gebe ihnen was
und ein bisschen später geben sie mir
etwas sie helfen
sie teilen futter und so weiter und das
muss ausgeglichen sein wenn es nicht
ausgeglichen ist und wenn ich wenn ich
nicht drauf achtet dann werde ich
allmählich ausgenutzt also was haben die
tiere entwickelt ich nenne das extrem
schmale trinkwasser rede von fairness
eine eine eine art von messgerät könnte
man sagen dass ich das ich schaue ob das
ein bisschen ausgeglichen ist und wenn
das nicht so ist dann zeige ich
emotionen das ist ganz eindeutig die
tiere sind emotional bei diesen serviert
sitzen weil er nun gut aber das ist wie
ich sag mal kinder moral denn das ist
ich werde nur wütend wenn ich zu wenig
bekommen
die werden nie wütend wenn der andere zu
wenig bekommt und das ist natürlich bei
menschen dazu bekommen unsere moral ist
eine ganz andere
es ist schon ziemlich anders als im
panzer moral zum beispiel weil unsere
moral ist die unterstützung für unsere
zusammenarbeit also ich würde auch
wütend werden wenn wir zusammen
unterwegs sind ich kriege immer trauben
sie nur gurken würde ich mich auch sehr
sie ein sehr genau das ist typisch
menschlich und kein tier macht das so
weit wir das nicht obwohl ich mich nicht
wundern würde wenn zum beispiel
bestimmte tiere die ihre jungen
gemeinsam aufziehen und auch gemeinsam
jagen so wie wir das schon machen denn
zum beispiel immer zurück zum homo
erectus wie die gejagt haben
stemmer vor das geht die haben das
gemeinsam gemacht aber der einfach per
zufall hat einen hat eine hat den tier
zerlegt und wenn er jetzt sagen würde ja
das ist jetzt mein tier ihr kriegt
dann würde das ganze zusammenbrechen
also man braucht ein eine sensor
fairness sagt man auf englisch eine art
von von wie verteilen wir jetzt diese
ressourcen so dass es ehrlich ist wenn
das nicht der fall ist dann bricht das
ganze zusammen und das ist teil der
moral und man kann zeigen die moral
das haben 1000 haben leute darüber
nachgedacht wo es herkommt es ist ganz
einfach wenn man schaut wie die jäger
sammler gelebt haben alle unsere
moralische präferenzen sind da um diese
lebensstil aufrechtzuerhalten damit es
nicht zusammenbricht damit die
kooperation die sehr intensiven sehr
kompliziert ist aufrecht erhalten wir
also moral als eine form von sozialen
kitt könnte man sagen sie haben ja so
hin
bei den menschen offen gesagt dass sie
sich im moment für diese krallenäffchen
interessieren da die dieses seiner
corporate branding machen dieses
gemeinsam aufziehen der jungen und dass
das wahrscheinlich so was wie ein
schlüssel ist in der ganzen mensch
werden
man kann also sagen tiere werden im
grunde genommen die die kleinen offen
babys werden dumm geboren die unsere
menschenbabys thun geboren werden sie
werden schlage machten wir uns sie
voneinander lernen in gruppen lernen
warum aber machen das denn die einen
tiere und die anderen nicht
der große unterschied ist und das kommt
wieder aus dieser gemeinschaftlichen
jungen aufzucht ist dass wir menschen
und unsere vorfahren wahrscheinlich uns
wirklich aktiv beteiligen
das wird zum beispiel lehren dass wir
unsere kinder nicht nur einfach gewähren
lassen und dass die kinder einfach das
machen was wir auch machen und dann wir
gehen einfach unsere normale routine ab
wir ändern unsere routine damit unsere
kinder besser lernen können wir lehren
tatsächlich schule kommt nicht von
ungefähr das ist etwas was sehr
menschlich ist und wenn man anfängt zu
leeren
es ist klar dass alle fähigkeiten sehr
schnell und effizient übertragen werden
aber dann kann man auch bei man
voneinander lehrt man gibt informationen
zu einander kann man als gruppe
natürlich viel mehr erreichen
und dann kommt allmählich auch eine art
rückkopplung prozess im gange
dass die hirne größer werden können um
ihr ex hat zum beispiel als erste art
eindeutig größere hirn als die
menschenaffen und da sehen wir eine art
von feedback loop wo die technologie
immer komplizierter wird und dass das
das ist alles ausgelöst davon dass wir
angefangen haben zu wehren das wiederum
kommt von diesen gemeinschaftlichen
jungen aufzucht also das war der
auslöser können wir sagen für all diese
andere prozesse
denn zum beispiel sprache ist ja
benennen das auf endlich informationen
der nation da wird statt futter wird
wissen geteilt informationen geteilt
andere tiere kunden kommunizieren zwar
aber gebe nicht so viel eigentlich
gesagt der club der claret informationen
denkt sie behalten das für sich man kann
also sehen dass die sprache aus dieser
aus diesem kern entstanden ist natürlich
hat es dann lange gedauert bevor wir
sprechen die wir jetzt sprechen aber
dass der grundsätzlich ist die sprache
positive informationsaustausch es gab ja
diese erzeugen die man versuche gemacht
hat die man heute gar nicht mehr machen
darf und menschen hoffen es gibt den
berühmten offen kann sie von dem es
unglaubliche videos gibt aber youtube
auf der alles kann und der versteht ja
sprache dem kann man sagen hole mir
meine schuhe und er bringt die schuhe
und man kann sich nur dann anziehen
er spricht aber selber nicht warum haben
denn affen nicht sprechen gelernt wenn
sie doch eigentlich verstehen kann also
er versteht sehr viel
das ist natürlich wieder eine frage die
die ganze evolution ist immer sehr
beschränkt in was wohin es springen kann
wir haben immer gedacht die sprache dass
sie so weit weg von alles was den affen
können
das können wir nicht evolutionär
erklären und was sehen wir jetzt kann
sie wird beim menschen aufgezogen
er wird so wie wir mit den hunden reden
und katzen
man hat mit ihm geredet und nach einer
weile hat man festgestellt
wir verstehen uns
natürlich eine unglaubliche überraschung
das zeigt das was wir die compression
das verstehen von sprache das
auseinandernehmen von diesen ganzen
strom von von lautäußerungen die das zu
uns kommen und diese in stücke zerteilen
die für uns mit wörtern korrespondieren
dass diese fähigkeit in den hirnen von
menschenaffen schon völlig da ist was
sie was überhaupt nicht da es ist die
produktion von diesem lautäußerungen
also utans die erfinden neue laute aber
das ist meistens nicht vor carl das geht
nicht mit dem kehlkopf
das sind sachen wie oder sowas und das
bedeutet also dass münchen tanzen
versuchen zu sprechen dann kommt man
nicht viel denn wir haben nicht ist
diese exchange soweit diese ganze
anatomie ist viel später entstanden
also es geht eigentlich nicht an der
hirnmasse oder an der intelligenz könnte
man sagen sondern ein an der
nato-mission ausgestaltung des
kehlkopfes und des raumes sie machen
einerseits natürlich aber das braucht
man erst wenn man sprechen möchte und
das problem ist die schimpansen
wir haben einander nicht zu sagen wir
haben nicht was wir dann so schön einen
an mitteilungsbedürfnis
und wenn das mal da ist das ist also
nicht eine kognitive änderung aber eine
motivation änderung wenn man möchte
informationen teilen mit angel jungen
aufzucht weder dann dann fängt an der
schneebar feld an zu rollen
berg runter und dann kommen die
anatomische änderungen auch dann am
anfang hatten das vielleicht auch mit
klicks und was weiß ich für komische
geräusche gemacht und allmählich ist an
die sprache daraus entstanden dass das
also das große mysterium wie kann so
etwas total neues wie sprache entstehen
ist nicht so mysteriös wenn man sieht
wie all diese elemente größten teil
schon da waren und nur ein paar sachen
dazu gekommen sind und wir müssen nicht
schon sehr schlau geworden seien vorher
um überhaupt zu sprach zu kommen
denn viele elemente lagen schon bereit
waren dafür etwas anderes müssen nur
zusammengefügt werden
sie sind ja anthropologe weltweit
renommierte fachgebiet haben schon ganz
viele forschergruppen angeleitet die
kernfrage der anthropologie was ist
eigentlich das wesen des menschen was
macht den menschen zum menschen ist
eigentlich eine philosophische immanuel
kant aber ganz ganz viele philosophen
immer wieder beschäftigt hat welche
antwort geben sie nach dieser
jahrelangen forschungsarbeit ja ich
meine wenn man man fragt mich ja häufig
menschen zu definieren dann sage ich der
mensch ist der kooperierenden
menschenaffe alles was wir verstehen
große intelligenz sprache kultur
technologie aus produkte von menschen
die uns so unglaublich einzigartig
machen gehen letztendlich zurück darauf
dass wir zusammenarbeiten und uns
gegenseitig unterstützen
also wenn ganz das was war es nochmal
was kann ich wissen
das ist die wissenschaft sehr dezent was
kann ich hoffen dass die religion sowie
in diesem ausmaß wie wir denn jetzt
haben während sind das ist ja noch sehr
neu sehr abgeleitet das ist ein produkt
der kulturellen evolution
aber was wenn wir das nicht tun was soll
ich tun das ist die moral
die geht es ja sehr weit zurück das ist
nämlich der baustein für unsere
zusammenarbeit ohne moral läuft nichts
bei menschen also kommt meinte ja
tatsächlich dass diese drei
philosophischen grundfrage diejenigen
sind die einen menschen umtreiben und
uns menschen eben zu menschen machen das
eben neugierig sind dass wir moral haben
dass wir gläubig auch sind die frage des
glaubens
denken sie es gibt tiere die irgendwie
so eine vorstellung haben von tanz
tendenz oder religiöse momente kennen
keine ahnung haben wir überhaupt keinen
zugang
aber es ist vielleicht interessant so
erwähnen dass bei den jägern und
sammlern diese ganze transzendenz frage
diese
es nochmal kontingents bewältigung das
ist auch keine große rolle spielt denn
die nehmen einfach anders sie
weiterleben in anderer formen macht er
nach dem tod
und dass das erst die wissenschaft hat
und zu diesen anderen fragen geführt
habe ich den eindruck
also sie haben wohin betont dass der
mensch eigentlich für sie der
menschenaffe ist der kooperieren könnte
man so weit gehen und sagen die
menschliche evolution der motor dafür
war eigentlich gar nicht der egoismus
sondern der autismus eindeutig also
egoismus das das ende bei allen tieren
eigentlich normalerweise natürlich die
nicht irgendwie von der zusammenarbeit
abhängig sind
ja das findet man in bar aber was was
wir gemerkt haben dass die große
intelligenz die sprache die die
unglaublich komplizierte technologie
das hängt alles von kooperation ab
egoistischer arten können das einfach
nicht entwickeln das ist kein keine
wertung seiner feststellung und deshalb
können wir sagen das was uns zum
menschen gemacht hat tatsächlich die
kooperation gewesen ist erlauben sie mir
zum schluss eine ganze zugespitzte frage
wir sagen oft wir leben heute im
zeitalter des egoismus
alle menschen sind sehr egoistisch
unterwegs ging wir demnächst unter
könnte sein aber das wichtigste ist wir
haben die die biologische evolution mehr
oder weniger im griff bekommen also ich
habe so eine brille zum beispiel wenn
die augen schlecht werden dann lösen wir
das problem und was weiß ich was für
alles lösen können
die kulturelle evolution die gibt es bei
menschenaffen fast nicht also das ist
wirklich etwas einzigartig menschliches
die geld natürlich seitdem wir in
unserer nahrung produzieren
schlagartig schnell von sich von staaten
also man kann nicht sehen muss was wo es
endet und das hat sich so schnell
etabliert wir ihnen hinterher also zum
beispiel die früheren gesellschaften
also die ersten städte und staaten
die waren unglaublich gewalttätig da
hatten die städte waren sogenannte des
treffs
kann man nicht zu sterben nicht um zu
überleben das haben wir im griff
bekommen
also wenn die kulturelle institutionen
die wir gebaut haben halten und die
werden immer besser das kann man zeigen
dann gibt es noch eine positive
nachricht das problem ist natürlich
klimawandel und so weiter menschen sind
unglaublich nett arbeiten immer
wunderbar zusammen aber nur mit in grub
nicht nicht mit den feinden und ich
hoffe immer noch dass es irgendwie eine
außerirdische zivilisation gibt die dann
sagt wir werden euch zerstören dann
halten wir immer sehr schön zusammen und
dann jetzt nicht gut kommen mit der erde
und klimawandel wird hoffen wir also auf
die marsmenschen so ungefähr alles
falsch einen herzlichen dank dass sie
mich durch dieses museum für
anthropologie geführt werden gern